Arjun opened up a savings account last
year and put
an initial sum in it. Let M of t
denote
the account balance M measured in dollars
t days since it was opened. What does
the statement
M of 30 minus M
of 0 equalling a hundred mean?
Before I look at the choices, let's think
about what this means.
When you input t equals 30 into your
function,
you're going to get M of 30.
So let me make that clear. So if you say t
is equal to 30, you input that into your
function
M. You're going to get -- you're going to
get
M of 30. So one way to think about it
is --
This is the account balance 30 days
since it was opened. This is when t is
equal to 30. This is the account balance
after 30 days
Let's write that down. Balance -- balance
after 30 days. Now, by the same logic, this
right over here this is when we put t
where we said t equals 0. This is the balance
after 0 days, or you could say this is
the initial balance.
initial -- initial balance.
So what they're doing -- they're taking our
balance after 30 days, and
from that they're subtracting the initial
balance and they're saying that
equal to 100.
So there's a couple ways you can
interpret this and I haven't even looked
at these choices yet. We'll see if
any of these match up.
You could say that your balance after 30
days is a hundred dollars more than the
initial
balance. Or another way to think about is
you added a hundred dollars in the first
30 days.
Those are both legitimate ways to think
about it. I'll see which of these choices
are
consistent with that. 30 days after it was
opened, the balance of Arjun's account
was
equal to 100. No, that's not what that's
saying.
This statement right over here -- the
balance 30 days after opening --
this statement right over here -- this
would be equivalent.
This is equivalent to saying that, M of
30 -- this is the balance after 30
days after it was opened --
is equal to 100. That's not what they tell us here.
They tell us that the difference
between the balance after 30 days and
the initial balance -- that's a hundred.
So we can rule that one out. Arjan had
the initial amount of money in his account
30 days after he opened it. So if he had
the same amount -- if he had the initial
amount -- let me
write this down. So had the initial
amount of money -- the initial
amount of money
is M of 0. So they're saying he had the
initial amount of money in his account
30 days after he opened it. Well, the amount
that he had in his account
30 days after he opened it is M of 30.
So these are the same amounts of money
then this --
In order to be consistent with this,
you would have an equation like this. M of 0,
the initial amount,
is equal to the amount after 30 days.
That's not what they told us over here.
We can rule that out. And then finally
we have the choice Arjan made a profit
over a hundred dollars
over the first 30 days since the account
was opened.
That seems reasonable that his balance
is a hundred dollars higher. The
difference between -- if you take the initial
balance and subtract it from his balance
after 30 days,
it's a hundred. And this right over here is a
hundred higher than his initial balance.
So it makes sense that maybe he got the
profit out of an interest or
something else
that he got in his bank account over the
first 30 days.